- poof poof - tall literacy is join the
tap nice wood hey mark tiny Barsoom is
here hey that's me
I'm unclaimed large box Larry hey that's
also me that's my medium box Molly what
the hell out on there something ain't
right
one of us should have been ice cream
Larry ice cream it's gonna start okay I
am The Spy so I'll be watching all of
the whispering that goes on okay or spam
with spring people yeah I'm just
everyone constantly oh my gosh so wait
what are you guys rules I'm a lookout
I'm the spy are we all town wait on you
bodyguard I can protect somebody are you
sure you all I don't want to trust you
all in case you're all lying
I don't just any one of you I don't know
evil don't kill me you know I'm not evil
I'm blue rabbit I'm bodyguard me blue
rabbit I'm the spine going done and done
did I die
thank God no large bag Larry I protected
you oh well I didn't think you were
actually and I ever lie after one person
killed him the Sira killer was all oh if
I stab them okay so you guys are telling
the truth right
yeah well wait definitely is okay okay
okay I am the sheriff I will admit that
on the sheriff well but what's your name
be you being the sheriff doesn't help us
Oh tell me your name I'm not gonna I set
my lame I am blue rabbit the spy I'm a
big lady no you're not I am tiny
Irishman okay
what do you say Jack I'll type poop okay
oh snap oh okay that could just be
coincidence okay
Boop toot and tiny box Tim is a serial
killer I just investigated him last
night
oh you were okay
box him in definitely serial killer yep
Tim's a little hot yeah yeah he doesn't
know that I investigated him last night
and I found out he was a seal because
that is quite sudden smuggling a true
serial killer he didn't even get to do
anything yet he killed large box
tortilla box Jim killed Larry oh man so
what what emotions
although guilty to innocence in there
okay later
who should I investigate an X you should
I'll investigate your alter ego toot
toot poop tube movie yeah I'm sold
investigate toot poof because that would
be me okay you're - poof I'm Foofa - you
guys are you serious wait yeah I am
since the bigger box is horrible things
I guard I don't know either me or you
know what that is
Who am I Who am I
oh god no um yeah Oh Jack watch Clint
Eastwood yeah okay I guess I guess
anyone medium box Molly was talking
about not wanting to okay I only do that
once
okay how about either chappie or a
medium box Molly yeah either those is
fine probably I bet medium box Molly's
not bad just because tiny box Tim was a
serial killer so I'm gonna do chappie
wait Jackie just sounds like a bad guy
yeah okay all right checking out chappie
the jailer has decided to execute you oh
god damn it
oh so many dead people oh no okay
chappie is not suspicious so he's either
like The Godfather or not suspicious you
keep dying so early I don't know I
didn't know okay so chappies good
literally they're number one dude the
odds of that happening wait did you see
anything last night I was bodyguarding
so no oh okay what wasn't one of us a
lookout Bob what are you I am the spot I
was okay nothing interesting has
anything Bob if you're playing us all
for a fool who's also mauled by a where
what's with these killers the werewolf
got lazy just one of the dead body all
right well now is this good time as any
to tell you guys I was actually number
one dude the whole time no you were
lying I trusted you and I killed Clint
Eastwood your spy on information from my
mafioso friends Wow I was really I was
really hoping I could run that the whole
time but that I did not I did not cheat
to that extent I only treated against
you myself okay good does that make you
feel better I feel
so kill is a werewolf or to ball feel
yeah you guys are already down - you
better start picking it up what was
large box Larry I don't even know no I
didn't get to see though well that's not
my problem I didn't get to see anything
about large box Larry you've been so
unhelpful this whole time they're not be
me boat don't go to poof don't do to
poof or poop - oh yeah I'm pooped - time
to protect weights oh yeah I know mark
and at night I protect him yes please
yeah do you guys really get each other's
backs but so if you protect me can you
not be killed I can oh he'll get me
killed
oh yeah but it XUI died protecting you
but I also kill them oh yeah cool so are
you just gonna protect me because that'd
be really cool Oh probably you choose
who should I investigate Chappy's good
we rabbit sounds funky yeah look at blue
rabbit
I'm not blue rabbit so I have no idea
what blue rapper one dude okay seriously
I was if you didn't notice our same
character yeah
well I probably would not pick another
mafia member to pretend to be so I like
it
literacy literacy you sure know what are
you doing well go for it I don't know do
you wanna know a secret
sooo late now blue blue rabbit is a
neutral killer not suspicious no
suspicious he was not suspicious because
Bob was withholding information the
whole damn time and literacy I did game
I can wreak havoc even though I'm dead
we're all happy working together now
jacks dead Bob's evil Jack Bob did you
kill Jack yes oh I know he was were you
actually a big lady jack yeah no I
didn't kill you Oh trust me friend have
you guys not learned about to trust me
yet seriously I wanna trust you Bobby so
nice you laugh so heartily oh my person
of an evil cackle hmm what wait you're
not gonna protect me well I am until I
find out who anyone else no offense but
you're not really the most important
role are you mark you're the mayor I'm
the sheriff sure sheriff is important
yeah I can find out
jailers dare boast sheriff finds things
out this is the dorinda pistols is done
what no what goes on in Ireland Jack
okay so I'm looking at literacy all
right yeah you should definitely
investigate literacy Bob I'm not
trusting you I'm investigating literacy
I don't care what you say literacy is it
definitely in the Mafia I'm not trusting
you I know he's in the Mafia don't try
to tell me otherwise I just told you he
is in the mob Oh Tommy
Bob's literacy you reverse psychology
won't work on me got quiet this
investigate literacy and see what
happens I am that's what I'm doing wait
which roles wait which roles kill the
people that visit them veteran and guard
you because I was hauled off to jail
damn it oh man oh man I was killed by
like a Jew
mark I told you the truth
did I not literacy was the mafia yeah
have I earned your trust yet you didn't
put in your will that literacy was mafia
no cuz I was too busy talking but that
doesn't matter literacy is dead and it
says he was in the Mafia oh I don't see
literacy die too busy being angry at the
jailer yeah exactly
oh wait do you know who the jailer is
then no this is Keenan okay so chappies
telling the truth princess Kenny is
probably bad boys you have to ruin
everything
I didn't actually do that much that time
Ted you did everything I told you that
literacy wasn't the Mafia and that was
an accurate statement yeah the werewolf
onna kill me anyway so it's like oh no
wait did the werewolf kill literacy a
werewolf killed literacy they just
happen to go to the same building as him
no I think the Mafia killed you didn't
they
it was also normal you were you were
mauled by the werewolf that's right yeah
so I wouldn't have been fine you were
right but I shouldn't have trusted you I
love spectating glad this is my episode
one
it's okay mark just just wreak havoc
with Wade now just get him go get him
body yard all right you got those bodies
you guard him good you guard all those
dead town bodies get all over those
bodies look him deep make sure you
checked all the cracks whoa whoa whoa
whoa checking the cracks yeah there's a
little bit of residue here
what kind of residue is it strong they
need to switch to a bed
toilet paper oh god there was so many
ways you could have gone to that joke
turn great alright I'm guessing medium
box Bali's actually sadistic in some
horrible character probably a werewolf
yeah medium box Molly might only be the
werewolf oh man I mean the most to
protect them we've just cleared sure
when they watch this afterwards they can
tell how much they screwed they can
still totally win the game for us no
they can't oh they can I guess what
random crap in web wait give me your
best jacket you died by doing an
impression to me I will says to do we
know Wade we read it we all saw you
don't pay attention to anything else if
I got to look you I'm dead okay like
fully and then I came out and died the
next day
so don't talk to me about dead
this year to spend your last few nights
a free man on three sides of the county
so just the town wait yet or what
oh no they're it's it's all town and
random there's just a werewolf and a
witch maybe a nanny I don't know who the
any is they're gonna kill Kenny those
bastards
you're watching other people play this
game right now
just commentating on what they could
possibly comes up the rear yams at home
lying on the floor just wasn't to poop
seems to be the bodyguards a great one
that's a plot twist if I've ever seen
plot twist is wait that was the jailer
becoming the gesture right please kill
chappy
no don't
mean by Molly's bad oh wow Planck was
the gesture hmm come on Blake werewolf I
guess I don't know yeah go werewolf
don't werewolf why not tonight
get a werewolf yeah get a werewolf yeah
yeah no more Wolf Wolf Wolf
can the werewolf and the witch win
together or do they have to fight each
other to the death because the witch
can't make the werewolf kill itself can
it else are we gonna do
so it's Debbie that's Malik speak oh the
world wars so media box Mollie is the
wish good I should have frickin
investigated medium box Mollie after
tiny box him
I knew something was suspicious I think
I actually said that I'm just saying
well I didn't want to listen to you you
lied to me no I you could have been the
insider on the Mafia that actually
helped us win that's not what mafias do
well I mean it could have been what you
do you're a rule-breaker a roll breaker
you like the Mafia guy from the family
yes Snipes I always I always cheat to
help the evil people though that's the
thing I do Zack I never I never cheat to
help the town I always see to help the
douchebags the witch and the werewolf
survive werewolf oh my god I've never
seen the werewolf win
well hey that's something special for my
video great
I didn't do it Paula take credit for oh
my god that was insane everyone can see
how beautiful you are hopefully this can
hide the shadow in my soul really good
last